what is up ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls of all ages it is Jerry and it's
time once again for some first
impression um I just got out of
transcendence which is the new film
directed by longtime cinematographer
Wally Pfister you probably know a lot of
his work from most of Christopher
Nolan's films and the ton of other stuff
he's done but this is his debut as a
director and um it's a pretty
interesting movie this i'm going to
start someplace different just because i
feel the need to this movie kind of
illustrates again what I don't like
about aggregate rating systems like
rotten tomatoes because while this movie
is not perfect I really think nineteen
percent is a pretty poor indicator for
the quality level of this movie but
anyhow on to the film itself
transcendence is definitely an ambitious
movie you get the sense that Wally
Pfister wants to make a you know a big
splash with his directorial debut and I
do gotta give the film credit for that
because it's mixed and and and in some
cases like really negative as some of
the reviews have been here I do always
prefer a movie that has too many
ambitions to a film that's you know just
lazy and this film isn't lazy by any
stretch i don't i don't think this is a
sort of ethically concerned science
fiction movie it has a lot of questions
about you know human consciousness
versus artificial intelligence and you
know when is too much technology and too
much blurring of the line between
consciousness and technology a bad thing
or a good thing or any of that first of
all you know the cast in this movie for
the most part is really spot-on rebecca
hall is fantastic paul bettany is
fantastic it's nice to see johnny depp
acting again in a role that isn't Jack
Sparrow or a similar kind of thing I
like Jack Sparrow and and I even like
The Lone Ranger but it seems like those
characters are really easy for him to do
and really fun for him to do but I've
been wanting him to go back to a little
bit more
of a serious role for a while and at
least as I'm feeling right now he does
come across as kinda rusty in this movie
which is a bummer but he's not bad I
don't think it bad but I certainly hope
he does more of these sorts of films
shake that rust off and the rest the
cast is good you know Morgan Freeman's
in here Killian Murphy's in here except
a collins jr. pops up Josh Stewart pops
up who I love I hope he continues to get
work a lot of people you know are on
loan from the Christopher Nolan
wheelhouse and um the film itself is
alright I like it there's definitely
stuff to be admired here there's a lot
of gorgeous cinematography there was
some really cool effects but beyond that
I mean there are some really great
scenes there are some really great
performances there are some beautiful
and interesting ideas and there are some
palpably scary and unsettling ideas and
it doesn't feel totally like your
stereotypical oh there is some really
wonderful human stuff in here and that's
definitely to be appreciated it's not
you know your big loud you know like a
sci-fi movie you know there's a bit of
action here and there but it's certainly
not a blow on me by any strategy does it
always work no partly because there are
times when at least I got pulled out
kind of thinking we'll wait a minute I
get that you're sort of set in a version
of the world where these things are
possible but you kind of gotta at least
fill in some of the gaps to me the stuff
that kind of hampers this movie from
time to time is basically the sense that
the ideas it wants to explore our
perhaps bigger than the intelligence of
the script itself there are certain
times where I found myself getting
caught up on like wait a minute why
didn't somebody catch this or how did
this become possible now there are times
when it seems like it's sort of counting
on you just to fill in the gaps and
sometimes that the pacing is a little
uneven but I definitely like it more
than I don't and there are a lot of
things to appreciate about it it's
definitely worth checking out I'm
interested to see how I'm going to feel
tomorrow when we sit down and do the
actual review and I'm interested to see
how I'm gonna feeling in a week or two
it's certainly worth checking out it
brings up some interesting ideas and it
does have an elegant touch with at least
some of them it does succeed on
some levels if it doesn't succeed on all
of them so I think it does certainly
deserve some credit it's not like a you
know [ __ ] waste of time by any
stretch of the imagination there is a
lot of care and effort in here it
doesn't always come across as capable of
selling and really coming to conclusions
on the idea as it puts out there all the
time and that's an element that sort of
always seems a bit problematic with
movies like these we've created a
computer with an artificial
intelligences doing things that we would
never have been capable of and it's
omnipresent and it's everywhere and it's
creating new technology and I feel like
that can sort of back a filmmaker into a
corner in terms of how can we make it
plausible when anyone takes a stand
against this thing so these movies have
a tendency to kind of pile stuff on and
get really really big in terms of
implications and things that start
happening and that chain reaction isn't
bad and there is some really cool stuff
that comes out of it but especially
toward the end there a couple of moments
where you're like whoa wait hold on a
second what you know but um there's
certainly some stuff that's worth
checking out here everyone involved
seems really committed and really into
it there's a lot of tender loving care
that went into this movie it seems like
it's not entirely successful but it's
worth checking out it does give you
something to think about and some stuff
to talk about and for someone who's a
first-time director with a film of this
scale you know it's it's certainly not
bad it's also a first-time rider so you
know it's big money and big toys but
it's also a couple guys who are cutting
their teeth still in terms of you know
writing and directing so um it's
admirable you know definitely let me
know what you think what's your favorite
sci-fi flick recently what's with
something new that's tickling your fancy
and as always comment subscribe check us
out in the tweets on Facebook and until
next time transcendence is the film I am
Jerry cheers